bonjour dépêchez vous julie vient
justement de réunir les enfants du
jardin pour leur raconter une histoire
ils sont là bas il était une fois et à
fort longtemps un petit chaperon orange
qui allait voir son grand père il lui
fallait pour arriver jusqu'à sa maison
traverser une grande forêt très sombre
et très profonde
il avait emporté dans son panier un
grand pont de gloubiboulga à bekasi mais
qu'est ce qui t'arrive que tout est
soufflé qui a fait la course
quels sont tes adversaires jeu dans les
pages courte ou sol mais je suis
surveiller contrôler entraîné
chronométrés dirigé par massoud us nord
il fait tout ça à la fois
ah oui enfin c'est moi ce qu'il prétend
mais dis moi pourquoi est en train de
tuer avec autant de sérieux
ah ben c'est pour améliorer ma forme ta
forme mais tu m'inquiètes tu es fatigué
non non pas du tout lors il s'agit de
cette forme là ah bon tu veux maigrir
oui c'est ça j'aimerais que ma forme
soit un peu plus ça comme ça va c'est
très bien mais il faudra pas que tu
exagères ans j'aimerais beaucoup être un
peu plus belle parce que j'en ai assez
d'entendre monsieur du snav nous traiter
de gros bas ligne mais quel est ton
programme d'entraînement ça vous
intéresse vraiment bien sûr mais moi je
parierais que tu as déjà fait le tour de
l'île à non non non c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça c'est en cross c'est
très difficile mais très efficace enfin
c'est du moins ce que prétend monsieur
du job et comment ça se passe il bien et
j'ai d'abord fait la première épreuve
alors la première époque j'ai d'abord
couru pendant 50 m à plat dans le sable
à ça ce n'est pas trop fatiguant oui
mais attend ce n'est pas tout ensuite je
courais toujours et j'ai grimpé une
bulle en cours en gérant descendu la rue
là où là c'est déjà plus ce n'est pas
tout j'ai encore couru 81 mettre à plat
dans le sable j'ai rencontré la bulle je
rentre descendu la lune et je traversais
toute la plage les mollets dans lourd
avec ça c'est excellent casimir
mais dis moi que faisait monsieur 10
noeuds pendant ce temps on pense temps
là il était hors de la dune
il me surveillait oui il chronométrait
chaque fois que jean renard qui sait ils
me traitaient le groupe bâlois a c'est
vraiment dur bon allez il faut que je me
prépare pour la deuxième est proche
la deuxième épreuve oui oui mais je
reviendrai devoir tout à l'heure ah bon
bah moi je continue mon histoire que
raconte une histoire qu'est ce que c'est
oui celle du petit chaperon range et de
sang globule garros et l'histoire que je
préfère j'aimerais bien rester
casimir tu viens pas la vie faut
vraiment que j'y aille si je veux
maigrir
monsieur 19 fait attention à lui à ne le
fatigue et pas trop vous inquiétez pas
il a dirigé sur place donc le petit
chaperon orange trottinait dans la forêt
avec son gros pot de gloubiboulga au
bras c'était un délicieux gloubiboulga
le chocolat râpé était parfait la
confiture de fraises était délicieuse la
moutarde était de dijon les balades
était mûr à point
quant aux saucisses de toulouse elle été
cru mais aura fait la partie de
l'histoire que je préfère
[Musique]
c'était un excellent gloubiboulga le
petit chaperon orange était sûr que son
grand père aimerait beaucoup ça elle
voulait surtout pas le donner aux chefs
des tyrannosaures juil qui on est
toujours au gloubiboulga enfin surtout
au petit chaperon orange ohlala
cette fois ça va être difficile sont pas
sûrs de réussir mais de quoi s'agit-il
voilà il s'agit d'un d'un triple saut
oui il faut tomber courir tombé sur le
petit droit le pied gauche
et puis les deux pieds je vais vous
montrer regarder ça se passe comme ça on
prend son élan hop c'est ça bon allez à
tout à l'heure
donc nous reprenons notre histoire
jamais rien faire jusqu'au bout bien je
continue bon ben moi je sais plus où
j'en suis vous savez vous les enfants où
on en est nos petits chaperons orange
120 avec son petit pot de groovy vigueur
voilà alors le petit chaperon orange
trottinant dans la forêt rencontre qui
devenait les enfants mais non il
rencontre son grand-père il s'approche
de lui il lui tend la main et il la
trouve très velud casimir qu'est ce qui
t'arrive tu tombé à l'eau mais non pas
du tout je viens de prendre mon bain
darabont c'est toujours stationnaire
mais tu te sens bien je suis très
content j'ai migré d'au moins quelques
centaines de grammes ce qui est très
bien c'est que monsieur du snam a promis
de s'occuper de moi tous les jours c'est
très bien quasi vire il faut persévérer
mais dis moi tu ferais bien d'aller de
sécher parce que tu vas attraper froid
bon j'y vais sur la raison donc il lui
tend la main et il la trouve très velud
il lève la tête et il trouve que ces ora
ils sont très longues
alors le grand père lui demande
qu'as-tu dans ton grand pau j'ai du
gloubiboulga répond le petit chaperon
orange du gloubiboulga c'est un plat
délicieux demande le grand père ont
certainement grand père répond le petit
chaperon rouge et
casimir qu'est ce que tu fais tu viens
pas écouté la fin de l'histoire
non non je ne peux pas il faut que je
mange un peu j'ai besoin de reprendre
des forces à aa
et qu'est ce que tu manges ou un tout
petit peu de gloubiboulga un peu de
bluebeam boulga mais dis moi c'est un
gloubi boulga chez oh ça tu n'as pas
honte
le jour où tu commences une cure
d'amaigrissement tu manges plus que
d'habitude pendant ça c'est pas fou
julie commence à ma faute mais oui
écoutent chaque fois que je passais près
du bord tu parlais de gloubiboulga je
n'ai pas pu résister mois quasiment